today we're talking about the future of
data mosquitoes and tick data analytics
i'm anthony and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
numerous factors underpin the challenges
of growing data volume including access
and storage inconsistent tools
new and evolving sources and formats
compliance concerns and security
considerations
to help you identify and solve these
challenges we've created a new white
paper the future of data will be unified
flexible and accessible which explores
many of the most common reasons our
customers tell us they're choosing
google cloud to get the most out of
their data
mosquitoes aren't just the peskiest
creatures on earth they infect more than
700 million people a year with dangerous
diseases like zika malaria dengue fever
and yellow fever
prevention is the best protection and
stopping mosquito bites before they
happen is a critical step
that's why google cloud was honored to
team up with one of the leading pest
control brands off
to develop a new publicly available
predictive model of when and where
mosquito populations are emerging
nationwide
learn more about the mosquito forecast
on the blog
we just published a blog post announcing
google cloud's latest stack m3 benchmark
results
following up on our 2018 stack m3
benchmark audit a redesigned google
cloud architecture achieved significant
improvements up to 18 times faster up to
9 times higher throughput and more
read more about these results and a
white paper on how we design and
optimize the cluster for api driven
cloud resources on the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud